hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
it's time for our fortnight meetup once
again every time something monumental
happens on the battle royale Island we
get together and look at the story so
far fought night battle royale has an
ever evolving storyline which seems
quite random at times but as each season
brings new live events we are slowly
piecing together law let's not mess
around chatting we've got tons to get
through so sit back relax use code a
damaru in the fortnight's shop and let's
go through fortnight battle royale the
story so far the first live event which
shook the in-game world started off as a
shooting star across the skies during
season 3 but as the days turned into
weeks that burning fireball in the sky
looked like more than a passing comet
lookout points and viewing platforms
were constructed around the island
welcoming the meteor we all tried and
failed to predict the day it would hit
us and some even predicted alien life to
be on board that UFO
[Music]
suddenly without warning pieces of the
comet began to hit the island destroying
man-made structures influencing fights
and causing havoc everywhere
with the introduction of season four
fortnight's island was finally hit by
more than debris large portions of the
former UFO destroyed many areas of the
map with the main impact destroying
dusty depot and turning it into a barren
hole in the ground instantaneously the
government erected barriers around the
impact site hiding away the central part
of the meteor those remains glowed red
potentially indicating life inside
elsewhere around the islands the cleanup
began with government officials
transporting the fragments of the comet
some of which grunted anti-gravity
abilities momentarily to anyone who
touched them tilted towers narrowly
avoided complete annihilation but one
building wasn't so lucky that building
and all the other areas were renovated
over the following weeks and months
finally it looked like all the fragments
and hot rocks were being transported to
a mountain over by snobby shores the
mountain was revealed to be a lair cut
into the rock face hidden from the
majority of the island some say it was
created for a movie shoot others believe
this was a facade and a secret
government facility is housed inside
especially as a rocket was seen either
way everything was about to change after
the final meteor fragment over by the
crater was discovered opened and whoever
was inside left a trail of destruction
all the way to the mountain lair the
visitor was revealed but nothing is
known about his origins he quickly found
a way to power the rocket and then came
the day he chose to launch broadcasting
the signal to all the televisions in the
vicinity either warning the innocent are
preparing them for annihilation was he
here to conquer us or was he simply
trying to get back home
what happened next only happened a
single time and could not be repeated
here's how it went down
the visitors somehow managed to create
ruptures in time and rifts between
dimensions although it looked like
tilted towers was about to be destroyed
a malfunction caused the rocket to warp
around the map the rift left behind
began to eat away at the four night
world with nom noms the tomato head and
the derp burger being ripped from this
reality and vanishing overnight but then
something even stranger happened items
from other worlds began to drop through
the rifts in time a stagecoach was found
above moisty mya a skeleton of a huge
animal or maybe a dinosaur or spotted in
moisty mire and a huge anchor was
spotted between snobby shores and greasy
Grove which look ancient in design
perhaps Roman perhaps knows something
was definitely happening here season 5
arrived and changed the world further
once the rifts in time and space opened
the drift character was dragged onto the
island alongside the fabled der burger
bright bomber and her crew showed drift
around the island and especially the new
areas to discover midway through season
five the crack in the sky began to burn
down a group of cactuses cacti cactus
cacti whichever is correct once all the
cacti were demolished the rift did this
a mysterious cube was created which
gifted shield when close enough but
would repel any damage at the closest
player to the cube so what did we all do
we all killed each other for a while
which was fun
eventually the cube began to roll around
the map and left Nordic runes in the
ground linking back to the nos team we
found in the battle paths and the theory
of Ragnarok bringing the end to the
current world over the next month the
cube went about its business including
smashing down the building and tilted
towers which has been under construction
since season 4 began epic just love to
trollers back to the loading screens saw
the arrival of the enforcers which look
like intergalactic police we'll have to
wait to see what happens here because
even on the last day of season 5 nothing
has been confirmed watch this space so
the cube finally made it over to loot
Lake and this happened
[Music]
the cube melted into loot lake causing
the top layer to become a repellant kind
of trampoline gel loot lake became
Thanos Lake or at least that's what the
community called it one week later
things changed yet again season six
began and the cube was not finished with
us yet
lifting the loot lake island into the
air
[Music]
the moment the floating island was
created the cube took it for a ride and
revisited all the room spots on the
island ripping them out of the ground
and transferring some source of energy
to them before moving on to the next
over two weeks the cube island moved
around the map slowly expanding itself
through the house above
once the cube reached the final room
another phenomenon happened all the
surrounding rooms were ripped from the
ground and pulled towards the cube this
time the cube was feeding from all the
rooms and over the next few days the
cube reached its full capacity
the floating rooms dropped from the sky
and hit the ground and the cube island
went back to its home above loot lake
with its newfound energy the cube
projected a beam of light into the air
and fought nightmares began
the island became infested with the
undead these husks were everywhere the
loot lake island was smashed into pieces
but with his job done the cube began to
drain away the energy and power it had
built up for the season opened a gateway
to a zombie Cataclysm for five days we
battled against the husks the nightmare
was almost over and to mark the end
another live event brought chapter one
to a close the end of the cube rest in
peace Kevin
here's how it went down
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
once given the cube left us replacing
loot Lake with leaky Lake we thought
this must be the end but as the rainbow
dulled the cold winter air kicked in and
the next episode in the saga began down
by flush factory a mysterious parachute
was discovered with the questionable
logo which could link to the satellite
surveillance found in save the world but
this wasn't our major concern because
out in the distance was a cloud of snow
quickly moving towards the island winter
is coming
suddenly aim was uncovered wearing the
exact same logo and subtly hiding in the
background of our games watching us
waiting and reporting back to someone or
something as season 7 began a huge
change to the island was witnessed the
cloud of snow hit an iceberg which hit
the island changing the entire lower
left third filling it with snow and icy
weather life went on with the destroyed
building in tilted towers once again
resurrected but for how long this time
the iceberg brought explorers to the
island who set up outposts across the
isle finally telling us who sent aim in
season 6 but this was only the beginning
as the iceberg slowly melted away
revealing a medieval castle underneath
for weeks we watched it thaw uncovering
a throne room and a dungeon below with
death traps tools of torture and sacred
dragon eggs something was going to
happen here a sword of immeasurable
power showed as the icebergs mysterious
potential and turned brother against
brother
until it was once again locked away
under ice we had a taste of godlike
power for a while the island was
peaceful again we collectively stopped
and saw in the new year together but far
more was yet to come
TV screens around the island sprung into
life again
warning of negative temperatures and
then it happened above the castle a
sphere as depicted in the Explorers
emblem appeared inside the ice ball was
the Ice King waking from his slumber
gaining strength and summoning mythical
energy and does that look a little bit
like Kevin just a little bit the
televisions once again counted down the
moments until the next live event began
the Ice King awake
[Music]
and that's where we currently stand the
Ice King has brought back the bloody
annoying zombies with ice powers this
time and the entire island is now snow
what do you think will happen next about
your favorites in the comments below if
you'd like to support me please think
about using the code a damaru in the
fortnight shop it makes a huge
difference to what I'm able to do anyway
let's meet up again when all this snow
has gone I imagine from Playstation
grenade it's been a pleasure I'll see
you next time
[Music]